welcome back to understanding Quantum information and computation my name is John watus and I'm the technical director for education at IBM
Quantum this is lesson number 15 of the series and it's the third lesson of the fourth unit which is on Quantum error
correction thus far we've seen a few examples of quantum error correcting codes including the nine Cubit Shore
code the 7 Cubit Steen code and the 5 Cubit code and we've also discussed the stabilizer formalism which provid
provides us with a mathematical Foundation from which we can describe and analyze these and many other Quantum error correcting
codes the codes that I just mentioned are undoubtedly interesting and they represent a natural place to begin an
exploration of quantum error correction the problem is that they can only tolerate a very low error rate
correcting an error on one cubit out of five seven or nine isn't bad but in all likelihood at least as far as we suspect
we're going to need to be able to tolerate a lot more errors than that in order to make large-scale Quantum Computing a
reality in this lesson we'll take a first look at some more sophisticated Quantum error correcting code constructions including codes that can
tolerate a much higher error rate than the ones we've seen so far and are viewed as promising candidates for practical Quantum error correction in
actual physical devices here's a brief overview of the lesson we'll begin with a class of
quantum error correcting codes known as CSS codes named for the researchers that first discovered them Robert calderbank Peter
Shaw and Andrew Steen the CSS code construction allows one to take certain pairs of classical
error correcting codes and combine them into a Quantum error correcting code as a part of that discussion we'll
take a pretty quick look at classical linear codes and we'll also talk about some of the basic properties of CSS
codes the second part of the lesson is on a code known know as the Torah code which is a fundamental and really
beautiful example of a Quantum error correcting code that can tolerate a relatively High error rate in fact the
Torah code isn't a single example of a Quantum error correcting code but rather it's an infinite family of codes one for
each positive integer starting from Two and in the last part of the lesson we'll briefly discuss a couple of other
families of quantum codes including surface codes which are closely connected to the torque code as well as
color codes people have been studying classical error correcting codes since the 1940s
and it's a fascinating and Rich subject linear codes are perhaps the simplest type of classical error
correcting code and I'll explain exactly what the word linear means in this context in just a moment but one simple
way to express what they are is that they're stabilizer codes that happen to be classical and we'll see shortly that
CSS codes are basically pairs of classical linear codes that are combined together to create a Quantum error
correcting code so for the sake of that discussion we're going to need to understand a few basic things about
classical linear codes first we're going to take Sigma to be the binary alphabet for this entire
discussion and now when we refer to a classical linear code we mean a set C of binary strings of length n for some
positive integer n satisfying just one basic property which is that if u and v are binary strings in C then the string
uxx ORV is also in C here by the way uxx ORV means the bitwise exclusive or of u and v just
like we saw multiple times back in lesson five and six in the quantum algorithms portion of the series and this is what it means for a
classical code to be linear in essence we're thinking about binary strings of length n as being n-dimensional vectors
where the entries are all either zero or one but instead of ordinary vector addition over the real or complex
numbers we're using addition modulo 2 which is simply the exor so if we have
two code words u and v meaning that u and v are binary strings in C then U plus v modulo 2 or in other words uux or
V must also be a code word in C and by the way this implication has to be true even if U is equal to V nothing rules
out that possibility and that implies that every classical linear code must contain the all zero string because the
bitwise exor of any string with itself is the all zero string for example the three-bit
repetition code is a classical linear code in particular there are two possible choices for U and two possible
choices for V and it's a pretty trivial matter to go through the possible pairs to see that we always get a code word when we take the bitwise
exor here's another example which is called the 743 Hamming code this is one of the very first classical error
correcting codes that was ever discovered and it consists of 16 binary strings of length seven there is a very simple logic
behind the selection of these strings but I won't explain that in this video and I should also mention that you will sometimes see these strings reversed but
for now the main point is that if we take any two of these strings and exor them together we'll get another string in the
code so it's a linear code and the notation 743 in single square brackets means something analogous to the double
square bracket not a I mentioned in the previous lesson for stabilizer codes but here it's for classical linear
codes in particular code words have seven bits There are 16 code words so we can encode four bits using the code and
it happens to be a distance three code meaning that you have to flip at least three bits of any one code word to get a
different code word and that implies that it can correct for up to one bit flip error these are simple examples of
codes but even the example of the 74 three Heming code looks kind of mysterious when we simply list all the code words so we need better ways of
describing classical linear codes and there are two natural ways of doing this one way is to describe classical
linear codes by giving a minimal set of code words that generate the code meaning that by taking all the possible
subsets of these code words and xoring them together we get the entire code and that's expressed in mathematical terms
here on the screen another way to think about this is that we're viewing this code as a Subspace of a vector space and this set
of generators is a basis for that Subspace keeping in mind that this is a vector space where arithmetic is done modulo 2 if we have M generators we're
going to end up with a code having two to the m elements each generator doubles the number of elements in the code and
that's consistent with the fact that classical linear codes over the binary alphabet always include a number of strings that's a power of
two the second natural way to describe a classical linear code is by parity checks specifically this is a minimal
list of binary strings having the same length as the strings in the code such that the strings in the code are precisely the ones whose binary
dotproduct with every one of these parity check strings is zero where the binary do product is simply the ordinary
inner product modulo 2 and again that's something that we encountered back in lesson five in the context of query
algorithms and the reason they're called parity check strings is that a given string U has binary product equal to
zero with v if and only if the bits of U corresponding to the ones in V have even
parity when we describe a classical linear code in this way by a minimal list of parity check strings each parity
check string divides the number of strings in The Code by two so for a single code described in these two different ways we'll always have m + Ral
n one important thing to notice here is that the binary dotproduct is not an inner product in a formal sense and in
particular when two strings have binary dotproduct equal to zero it doesn't mean that they're orthogonal in the usual way that we think about
orthogonality for example the binary do product of the string one one with itself is zero so it is possible that
one of these parity check strings is itself in the codee so that's just something to keep in
mind for example as we already know the 3-bit competition code is a linear code so it can be described in both of these
ways in particular there's only one choice for a generator that works and that's 111 and we can alternatively describe
the code with these two parody check strings which should look familiar from our previous discussions of this
code and for the 743 hemming code we can use these generators and these parody
checks and here by the way all of our parody check strings turn out to themselves be in the code
code a final comment about classical linear codes just to connect them to the stabilizer formalism these parody check
strings are equivalent to stabilizer generators where we only have Z and identity polym matrices for example the parity check
strings 11 0 and 011 for the 3-bit repetition code correspond precisely to the stabilizer generators ZZ identity
and identity ZZ and that's consistent with our discussion of observables of this sort from the previous
lesson next we'll discuss CSS codes which are stabilizer codes that can be obtained by combining together certain
pairs of classical linear codes having the same number of bits in their encodings this doesn't work for any two
classical linear codes the two codes have to have a certain relationship as we'll see shortly but nevertheless this
construction does open up a lot of possibilities for Quantum error correcting codes based in part on things that we've learned from over 75 years of
classical coding Theory I've already mentioned that in the stabilizer formalism stabilizer
generators containing only Z and identity poly matrices are equivalent to parity checks for example in the three-bit
repetition code we can use the parody check strings 1 1 0 and 011 which enforce that the leftmost two bits are
equal and the rightmost two bits are equal for every string in the code and these two parity check strings correspond precisely to the stabilizer
generator's ZZ identity and identity ZZ for the 743 Heming code we can use
these parody check strings and they correspond to these stabilizer generators where we simply replace each one by a z and each Zero by the identity
you might recognize these stabilizer generators by the way because these are three of the six stabilizer generators for the 7 Cubit steam code that's
certainly not a coincidence and we'll see exactly what's going on here shortly we're going to give the name Z
stable ster generators to stabilizer generators like this meaning that they only have poly Z and identity tensor
factors so X and Y never occur in a z stabilizer generator we can also consider
stabilizer generators where only X and identity poly matricies appear and we can think about stabilizer generators like this as being completely analogous
to Z stabilizer generators except that they basically describe parity checks in the plus minus basis rather than the
standard bases for example going back to the 743 Heming code we can think about the
remaining three stabilizer generators from the 7 Cubit steam code which happen to follow exactly the same pattern as for the Z stabilizer generators for this
code but this time we substitute X for one rather than Z and what we get from just these three stabilizer generators
is a code that includes the 16 states that are shown here which we get by applying hadamar gates to the standard
basis states that correspond to the strings in the 743 Hamming code and of course our code space also includes
linear combinations of these states naturally stabilizer generators of this form are called X stabilizer generators
so no y's or z's are allowed this time and now we can Define CSS codes in
simple terms CSS codes are stabilizer codes that can be expressed using only Z
stabilizer generators and X stabilizer generators so no y's allowed and no x's and Z's appearing in the same stabilizer
generator and just to be sure that this is clear we should keep in mind that there is freedom in how we choose the stabilizer generators for stabilizer
codes and what this definition is saying is that a CSS code is one for which it is possible to choose just Z and X
stabilizer generators but in general you could choose different stabilizer generators that might not be Z or X stabilizer generators if you wanted
to here's just about the simplest non-trivial example of a CSS code we can have where there's both a z stabilizer
generator and an X stabilizer generator and verifying that requires no more than a glance given that we already know from
the previous lesson that this is a valid stabilizer code the code space is one-dimensional it's the space span by a
five Plus Bel and we can observe that our two stabilizer generators act trivially on this vector by considering
the two expressions of an ebit shown on the screen together with the interpretation of the stabilizer generators as parity checks in the 01
and plus minus bases the 7 Cubit steam code is another example of a CSS code because for this
choice of generators we only have Z and X stabilizer generators and again we already know that this is a valid
stabilizer code and the N9 Cubit short code is another example this time we have six Z
stabilizer generators and just two x stabilizer generators and that's fine there doesn't need to be a balance or a
symmetry between the two types it is however critical that we actually have a valid stabilizer code and that means
that each of the Z stabilizer generators must commute with each of the X stabilizer generators so you can't
simply choose the two types of generators independently and I'll say a little bit more about this later in the lesson next we'll discuss error
detection and correction for CSS codes and what we'll find is that the property that we observed for the 9 Cubit Shore
code that we can detect and correct X errors and Z errors independently holds in general for CSS codes
to explain this further let's consider a CSS code such as the 7 Cubit steam code but it could be a different CSS code if
you prefer the basic idea is that the Z stabilizer generators detect X errors
but they're completely oblivious to Z errors because Z stabilizer generators always commute with Z
errors in addition the Z stabilizer generators also commute with whatever Z Gates we might choose to apply as
Corrections for Z errors similarly the X stabilizer generators detect Z errors but they're completely
oblivious to X errors and Corrections so we can in essence think about the Z stabilizer generators as representing a
classical linear code that protects against bit flips or in other words x errors well the X stabilizer generators
represent a classical linear code in the plus minus basis that completely independently protects against flips
between plus and minus States or in other words phase flip errors or Z errors so now it's quite apparent what's going
on with the steam code it's simply a 743 hemming code for bit flip errors and a 743 Hamming code for phas flip
errors once again the fact that the Z stabilizer generators and X stabilizer generators commute is required it
wouldn't be a valid stabilizer code if they didn't and you could say that it's good fortune that the 743 Heming code
works out like this but there are a lot of other choices that can be made for pairs of classical linear codes that will give us a valid stabilizer code
when combined in this way now getting back to CSS codes in general suppose that the Z stabilizer
generators allow for the correction of up to say JX errors and the X stabilizer generators allow for the correction of
up to k z errors so in the case of the steing code J and K are both one because
the 743 hemming code can correct one bit flip but in general these numbers J and K could be different
it then follows by the discretization of errors that the CSS code can correct for any error on a number of cubits up to
the minimum of J and K that's because when we measure the syndrome an arbitrary error on some
number of cubits effectively collapses probabilistically into some combination of X errors Z errors or both and then
the X errors and Z errors can be detected and corrected independently so as long as we have two
classical linear codes that get along in the sense that they give us x and z stabilizer generators that commute the
CSS code we get by combining them basically inherits the error correction properties of the two codes in the sense that I've just
described notice that there is a price to be paid though which is that we can't encode as many cubits as we could bits
with the two classical codes because the total number of stabilizer generators for the CSS code is the sum of the
number of parody checks for the two classical codes and each stabilizer generator cuts the dimension of the codee space in
half for example the 743 Hamming code allows for the encoding of four classical bits because we have just
three parody checks for this code whereas the 7 Cubit steam code only encodes one cubit because it has six
stabilizer generators the last thing I'll explain about CSS codes in general in this lesson concerns code spaces of CSS codes
and what they look like and this will also give us a chance to examine in a little bit more detail the relation relationship that needs to hold between
two classical linear codes in order for them to be compatible in that we can combine them together to form a CSS
code consider an arbitrary CSS code on N cubits and let Z1 through Zs be the nbit
parity check strings that correspond to the Z stabilizer generators this means that the classical
linear code described by the Z stabilizer generators which we'll call CZ just to help us to remember that this
is the code corresponding to the Z stabilizer generators takes the form that's shown here on the screen in words the code contains every
string U whose binary do product with each of the parody check strings is zero well if we wanted to we could also
consider a different code derived from these same strings which we'll call DZ and the idea here is that we think about
these strings Z1 through Zs not as parity check strings but rather as generators
at this point it isn't clear why we would want to think about this code but we can and it'll turn out to be relevant to this
discussion this code is called the Dual code of CZ and it's commonly denoted CZ per meaning CZ with the perpendicular
symbol as a superscript but we're going to call it DZ and that'll be easy enough to remember because D is short for
dual we can also do something similar with the X stabilizer generators so this time CX is the classical linear code
whose parity check strings correspond to the X stabilizer generators and DX is the Dual code of this code as an aside
we can now describe the conditions that must hold in order for CZ and CX to be compatible in the sense that we can
paare them together as a CSS code in terms of these codes themselves specifically it must be that
DZ is contained in CX or equivalently that DX is contained in CZ and now it's
possible to describe the code space of the CSS code derived from these two codes and one way to describe it is that
it's the space Spann by all of the vectors that take the form that's shown on the screen in words they look like uniform
superpositions over the strings in the Dual code DX of the code corresponding to the X stabilizer generators shifted
by or exord with strings in the code CZ corresponding to the Z stabilizer generators and we'll see what this looks
like in the specific case of the steam code in just a moment this makes sense because states in the code space must be
plus one igen vectors of all the stabilizer generators and in particular multiplying by any one of the X
stabilizer generators is equivalent to xoring by the corresponding X string so that's why these uniform superpositions
over DX shifted by different strings appear like this different choices for the shift
represented by the string Y in this expression can give us the same vector by the way so these states aren't all distinct but collectively they expan the
entire code space there is a symmetry here between the x and z stabilizer generators and
the codes that they correspond to and so we can use that symmetry to describe vectors in the code space in an analogous way swapping x's and Z's but
we also need to swap the standard bases for the plus minus bases which is why the hatam operations appear in this
expression now for the example that was promised which is the steam code we end up with these two encoded as possible
encodings of the zero and one standard basis States in particular we can encode the zero State as a uniform
superposition over the eight strings in the Dual code of the 743 Hamming code which turns out to be half of the strings in the 743 Hamming code and we
can encode the one state in a similar way except that all the strings are exor by the all one string in this case
because that string happens to be in the 743 hemming code but not in its duol one final comment here is that we often
don't actually care all that much about what vectors in our code spaces look like because we generally don't need to know this in order to use the
codes so if this explanation wasn't clear it's really not something to worry about too much but it is certainly
natural to ask what vectors in code spaces of CSS codes look like and this description provides an answer to that
question next we'll discuss a specific CSS code known as the Torah code which is an example of something known as a
topological quantum error correcting code this code was discovered by Alexa kayv in
1997 in fact the Torah code isn't a single code but rather it's a family of codes one for each positive integer at
least two these codes possess some Key Properties the first key property is
that all of the stabilizer generators have low weight as poly operations in particular they're all going to have
weight four and this is good because it means that each of the stabilizer generator measurements doesn't need to
involve too many cubits sometimes people speak of quantum ldpc codes or Quantum low density parity
check codes and this is what is meant by this term where in this case low means four so the Tor code is an example of a
Quantum ldpc Code the Tor code also has what's called geometric locality which means that not
only do the stabilizer generators have low weight but it's also possible to arrange the cubits spatially so that
each of the stabilizer generator measurements only involves cubits that are close together which makes these measurements easier to implement in
principle and finally these codes have large distance so they can tolerate a relatively High rate of
Errors here's how these codes work first let capital L be a positive
integer that's at least two and consider an L by L lattice with so-called periodic IC
boundaries for example here's an L by L lce for Lal 8 and notice that the lines
on the right and on the bottom are dotted lines and the idea here is that we want to think about the dotted line on the right as being the same line as
the line on the left and similarly the dotted line on the bottom is the same line as the one on
top so if we actually wanted to realize this sort of configuration physically we'd need three
dimensions in particular we could form a cylinder by first matching up the left and right sides and then bend the
cylinder around so that the circles at the ends which used to be the top and bottom edges of the lattice meet or you
could match up the top and bottom first and then the sides it works both ways and it doesn't matter which way you do it for the sake of this
discussion what we get is a Taurus or in other words a donut although thinking about it as an inner tube of a tire is
perhaps a better image to have in mind because this isn't aoft the lattice has actually become just the surface of a
Taurus and this is where the name Torah code comes from the way that you can move around on
a Taurus like this assuming that you're able to move between adjacent points on the lattice will likely be familiar to people that have played old school video
games where if you move off the top edge of the screen you emerge in the bottom and likewise for the left and right edges of the
screen and for the most part this is the way that I'll describe this lattice as a oos to talking specifically about a
Taurus in a three-dimensional space next we imagine that cubits are
placed on the edges of the lattice as is Illustrated here on the screen where cubits are indicated by solid blue
circles notice by the way that the cubits that are placed on the dotted lines aren't solid and that's because we've already represented those cubits
either by the ones along the top or the left hand side keeping in mind that the lines on the top and the left are exactly the same lines as the ones
indicated by the dotted lines on the bottom and the right and so if we count up all of these cubits we get 2 * l^ 2 cubits and one
way to see that is to observe that we get l s cubits on horizontal edges and L squar cubits on vertical
edges so that's the layout of our cubits and to describe the Tor code itself we just need to describe the stabilizer
generators and there are two types of them first we have Z stabilizer generators
and these correspond to tiles or pletes in the figure and second we have X stabilizer
generators and these correspond to vertices in the figure so for example here's one
stabilizer generator meaning that we're tensoring together one poly Z operation for each of the cubits that are touching this tile along with identity matrices
on all the other cubits and that gives us a weight for poly operation and here's an example of an X
stabilizer generator where we have poly X matrices acting on the four cubits incident to this vertex along with
identity matrices on all of the other cubits so once again it's a weight for poly operation it's important that for both
of these types of stabilizer generators we include the ones that wrap around at the periodic boundaries and here's an example of an x- stabilizer generator
that does this now in order to get a valid stabilizer code we need the stabilizer
erators to commute the Z stabilizer generators all commute with one another because Z commutes with itself and the identity
commutes with everything and likewise for the X stabilizer generators it's also clear that a z stabilizer generator and an x-
stabilizer generator commute when they act non-trivially on disjoint sets of cubits like for the two generators that are shown
here the remaining possibility is that a z stabilizer generator and an X stabilizer generator overlap and
whenever that happens it's always two c on which they overlap and so the stabilizer generators commute because ZZ
and xx commute now this is not a minimal set of stabilizer generators in particular if we multiply
all of the Z stabilizer generators together we get the identity because every Cubit gets multiplied by z twice
once for each of the tiles that touches the Cubit that means that multiplying all of the Z stabilizer generators together
except for one of them gives us that last one so they're not independent but if we remove any one of them we will get
an independent set and the same is true for the X stabilizer generators so we can remove one of each
and it doesn't matter which ones we remove and that leaves l^2 minus one stabilizer generators of each type to be
clear about this and this is something that I alluded to in the previous lesson we actually do care about all of these stabilizer generators and in a strictly
operational sense we won't actually pick one of each type to ignore but but for the sake of analyzing the code we can
imagine that one stabilizer generator of each type has been removed so that we get a minimal generating set keeping in
mind that we could always infer the results of these removed generators thinking of them as observables from the results of all of the other stabilizer
generator observables of the same type so the number of cubits that this code encodes is equal to the total number of
cubits which is 2 * l^2 minus the total number of stabilizer generators in a minimal gener in set which is 2 * l^2 -
1 and that means we can encode 2 cubits I didn't argue by the way that the code space is non-trivial but indeed
it is non-trivial and I'll leave it to you to convince yourself that there's no way to multiply together stabilizer generators in a way that gives us
negative -1 times the identity so that is the Torah code itself and at this point it may not be
clear at all why this code should be good for Quantum error correction it remains for us to analyze it and what we'll find is that it is in
fact a pretty amazing Quantum error correcting code to understand how the Torah code functions as a Quantum error correcting
code we'll Begin by considering different errors and the syndromes that they generate the first thing to note is that
the Tor code is a CSS code because all of our stabilizer generators are either Z or X stabilizer
generators and what that means is that X errors and Z errors can be detected and possibly corrected
separately and in fact there's a simple symmetry between the Z and X stabilizer generators that allows us to analyze X
errors and Z errors in essentially the same way so I'm going to focus on X errors which are possibly detected by Z
stabilizer generators and you can translate everything to Z errors which are possibly detected by the X stabilizer generators using exactly the
same ideas here's a figure illustrating our two Square cubits on the edges of an L
by lattice with periodic boundaries and we can imagine that this is laid out on the surface of a
Taurus at the moment all of the cubits are blue indicating that these are cubits that haven't been affected by
errors so you should imagine that at this point the state of these cubits is in the code space for this
code as I mentioned our Focus will be on X errors and in just a moment we'll use magenta circles to indicate cubits that
have been affected by X errors X errors are detected by Z stabilizer generators which correspond
to tiles in the figure so what we can do is to let White Tiles indicate plus one measurement outcomes or in other words
entries in the syndrome corresponding to that generator while gray tiles will indicate minus one measurement
outcomes you can think of a plus one outcome or in other words a white tile as indicating that the corresponding
stabilizer generator is Happy everything seems to be okay for this generator well a minus one outcome or a gray tile
indicates that the corresponding stabilizer generator is unhappy because obviously an error must have happened to cause this
outcome so at the moment all of our stabilizer generators are happy because no errors have occur now if we think
about a z stabilizer generator all that it's doing is measuring the parity of the 4 cubits that touch the tile with
respect to the standard basis so a plus one outcome doesn't indicate that no X errors have occurred on these four
cubits but rather it indicates that an even number of X errors have occurred whereas a minus one outcome indicates
that an odd number of X errors have occurred so now let's introduce an X error and see what
happens the two Z stabilizer generators corresponding to the tiles that touch this Cubit are now unhappy because this
x error anti-c commutes with both of these generators or equivalently in terms of the standard basis we're now in
a state where both of these sets of four cub bits corresponding to the two tiles have odd parity so that's the effect of a single
X error so if we were to measure this syndrome and we knew or we assumed that just One X error had occurred we'd be
able to easily infer which Cubit had flipped and we could simply flip it back with an xgate now let's see what happens
when we introduce additional X errors and in particular let's see what happens when a second X error occurs on another
Cubit touching one of the gray tiles let's say the gray tile on the top like
this that tile is now happy because two x errors have occurred on the cubits touching this tile and two is even so
these two x errors together commute with the stabilizer generator for this tile another way to say this is that
this second X error has shifted all the standard Bas of states for these four cubits from odd parity back to even
parity the tile to the left of this new X error on the other hand is now unhappy
we can continue this process of adding new X errors and as long as we form a chain of adjacent X errors where adjacent means that the cubits touch the
same tile we'll effectively push this minus1 measurement outcome around and what we find is that we always have
minus one syndrome measurement outcomes at the end points of chains of adjacent errors so we can always detect chains of
adjacent X errors as long as they have end points there could by the way be multiple chains but but we'll come back
to this possibility later it is possible however that we can have a chain of adjacent X errors that
doesn't have n points which is to say that our chain of Errors could form a closed loop so let's add some more errors so
that they form a closed loop like this for instance we now have an even number of X
errors on every tile so every stabilizer generator is now happy and what we found is that Clos
Loops of adjacent X errors are not detected by this code because we obtain the all plus1 syndrome in such a
case so that might seem kind of disappointing in fact we only need four adjacent X errors to form a closed loop
and we're hoping for something better than a distance 4 code however some closed Loops of
adjacent X errors are themselves in the stabilizer remember that we have an X stabilizer generator for each vertex in
the lettuce and if we mult multiply together adjacent X stabilizer generators we can form closed Loops of X
operations such as we have right here for the closed loop that we constructed just a few moments ago so some closed Loops of X errors
like the one that's shown here aren't actually errors at all because they are in the stabilizer so they do nothing at all to the code space there are however
some closed Loops of X errors that are not in the stabilizer and therefore they represent non-trivial errors that go
undetected by the code and there's a pretty simple way to characterize the different types of
loops loops that cross every line in the lattice meaning every vertical line from top to bottom and every horizontal line
from left to right an even number of times are always products of X stabilizer generators that includes the example
shown on the screen as well as Loops that may be much more complicated including the possibility that they cross the periodic boundaries but
nevertheless by multiplying these closed Loops of x Errors By X stabilizer generators they can effectively be shrunk down to
nothing and it's certainly True by the way that we can only get loops like this by multiplying together X stabilizer generators because every X stabilizer
generator puts an even number of X operations on every horizontal line and on every vertical
line the other type of closed loop we can have is one that crosses at least one line an odd number of times such as
the one that's shown here which crosses every horizontal line just once and here's another example that crosses
each vertical line just once so these are examples of non-trivial errors that go undetected by the code but the key
here is that the only way to form a closed loop like this is to go around the Taurus either around the hole in the
middle of the Taurus or through the hole or it could be both this is a topological property
concerning aurus it's all about the holes basically and that's why this is called a topological Quantum error Cor
code in terms of this visualization of a two-dimensional lattice with periodic boundaries a chain in this category must
loop around one or both of the periodic boundaries in a way that makes it impossible to contract that Loop to a
point by multiplying it by X stabilizer generators such a chain might be more
complicated than the one that's Illustrated here but this is the shortest that such a loop can possibly be because it has to somehow loop around
one or both of the periodic bound boundaries and what this implies is that the minimum weight of a non-trivial
undetectable error is L any closed loop with fewer errors than that must fall into the first category and is therefore
in the stabilizer and chains of errors that don't form closed Loops are detected by the code and that's it that's why this code
works and what we end up with is a 2 l^2 2 L stabilizer code we're using 2 L S
cubits to code 2 cubits and the code has distance L next I'll say just a little bit about
correcting errors with the Torah code though I won't go too far into the details if we measure the syndrome and
we see something other than the all plus1 syndrome where I'm speaking here about just the Z stabilizer generators
then the minus one outcomes indicate to us the end points of one or more chains of adjacent X errors and we can attempt to correct
these Errors By pairing together the minus one outcomes and forming a chain of X Corrections between them and as
we're doing this it makes sense to choose shortest paths for our Corrections for example if we measure a
syndrome such as the one that's shown here then we could choose this path between the unhappy tiles and apply X
Gates as Corrections along this path of course the actual chain of Errors causing the syndrome could have
been different such as the one that's shown here but that's okay as as long as the errors and the corrections together
fall into the stabilizer it could also be that our Corrections complete a loop around the
Taurus which is bad because in doing this we've caused a logical error so this strategy of correcting
along shortest paths corrects low weight errors but it might not work for higher weight errors but of course we can't
expect anything more from any Quantum error cting code more likely perhaps depending upon the noise model is that
we observe a bunch of minus ones in the syndrome and in this case we can use efficient classical algorithms to help
us to pair them up and find a lowest weight error representing the syndrome as I mentioned in the previous
lesson this may not always correct the most likely explanation for the syndrome but it does work pretty well in general
and it always succeeds in correcting errors having weight strictly less than half the distance L and I should also
mention that there are other strategies that are better Suited Ed to different error models it's been over 25 years since the
Tor code was discovered and in that time there's been quite a lot of work on Quantum error correcting codes including
other topological Quantum error correcting codes inspired by the Torah code as well as codes based on different
ideas I certainly can't give you a comprehensive list of all of the different code constructions that are known but I will scratch the surface
just a little bit and briefly mention a couple of well-known examples first as a turns out it isn't
really essential that the Tor code has periodic boundaries that is it's possible to cut out just a portion of the Tor code and
lay it flat on a two-dimensional surface rather than on a Taurus and what we get by doing that is called a surface
code for instance if we cut the edges of a lattice in the pattern that's shown here with so-called rough edges at the
top and bottom and smooth edges at the sides and correspondingly we include edge cases for the stabilizer generators
then we end up with a code that can encode just one Cub at this time but the code nevertheless inherits the most
important characteristics of the Tor code in particular non-trivial undetectable errors for this code must
correspond to chains of errors that either stretch from the left Edge to the right Edge or from the top to the bottom
depending on whether they're chains of X errors or Z errors respectively it's also possible to cut
the edges diagonally to obtain what are sometimes called rotated service codes and doing that can be helpful for making
the codes more economical in terms of how many cubits are used for example if we take this surface
code and we throw away some of the cubits leaving a square oriented diagonally we obtain another service
code so long as we specify the stabilizer generators on the boundary in the right way diagrams like this are
helpful for making clear how the stabilizer generators are defined where black tiles including the rounded ones at the edges indicate X stabilizer
generators and the white ones indicate Z stabilizer generators the ones on the boundary by the way are just 2 Cubit XX
or ZZ stabilizer generators this time and you'll commonly see these diagrams rotated by
45° another interesting class of codes which also fall into the general category of topological codes are color
codes I won't explain exactly how they work but one way to think about them is that they're geometric generalizations
of the 7 Cubit steam code so let's consider the seven cubits team code and suppose that we number our
cubits using the KCET ordering Convention as is shown here on the screen we can then associate these seven
cubits with the vertices of the graph that's shown here and what we find is that the stabilizer generators match up
with the tiles or the faces that are formed by the edges of the graph and for each tile we always have a z stabilizer
generator and an X stabilizer generator that act non-trivially on precisely those cubits that are found at the vertices of that
tile this is nice because just like for the Torah code we have geometric locality for this code so we don't need
to move cubits over long distances to measure stabilizer generators and the fact that the Z and X stabilizer generators always act non-trivially on
exactly the same sets of cubits is also nice for reasons connected with fault tolerant Quantum computation which I'll
say more about in the next lesson color code are quantum error correcting codes that generalize this
basic pattern where we do essentially the same thing except with different graphs for example here's a graph with
19 vertices that works this gives us a code that encodes 1 Cubit into 19 and it happens to have
distance five these are called color codes by the way because one of the required conditions on the graph is that the faces can be three-colored meaning
that we can color the faces with three colors and we never have two faces of the same color sharing an edge the
colors don't actually matter for the code itself we simply have x and z stabilizer generators for each face regardless of its color but the colors
do turn out to be important for analyzing how it works so those are two very well-known
families of codes but there are many other constructions that are known including ones that are based on ideas similar to these code families as well
as completely different ones a specific example of a Quantum error correcting code that was recently
discovered by some of my colleagues at IBM is known as the gross code which is so named because a gross is a dozen
dozen or 144 in particular this code encodes 12 cubits into 144 cubits and it has
distance 12 I won't explain how this code Works in detail it's similar to the Tor code except that each of the
stabilizer generators now involves two additional cubits that are just a little bit further away it doesn't have a planer embedding
like a surface code but it does have a so-called Baner impeding meaning that two layers of cubits are needed rather
than one it falls into a family of codes called byari bicycle codes and what's particularly remarkable about them is
that they're much more efficient than the Torah code or a surface code in the sense that a lot more cubits can be encoded while simultaneously they
tolerate roughly the same rate of Errors for the gross code an additional 144 cubits are needed for the syndrome
measure so the total number of cubits required is 288 which makes it a very promising candidate for today's
technology and that concludes this lesson which has been on constructions of quantum error creating codes including CSS codes the Torah code and a
glimpse at other Quantum Code constructions including surface codes and color codes I hope you will join me for the
next and final lesson of the series on fault tolerant Quantum computation which addresses the challenge of Performing
comp computations un encoded Quantum States using operations and Computing components that are themselves prone to
errors goodbye until then